und sind sie am montag auch an ihrem
limit gekommen absolute grenze erfahrung
sechs stunden ohne facebook whats app
instagram man da ging gar nichts mehr
weltweit technische probleme und ein
albtraum natürlich vor allem für die
jungen digital native sechs stunden
keine lustigen schlumpf videos von tante
hildegard auf whatsapp gar keine fremden
frauen auf facebook beschimpfen können
millionen menschen wurden gnadenlos
reingeworfen in diese analoge realität
man wollte ich mich noch mit freunden
treffen per sms geschrieben das war auch
was ganz los ich würde gerne meinen
eltern schreiben aber das ist jetzt
nicht möglich und daher weiß ich nicht
wirklich was ich tun soll ja sehr
schwierig für uns alle gerade für alle
jugendlichen
ganz schwere zeit
horror
kostenloser boomer tipp von mir fürs
nächste mal einfach zu diesem super
neuesten gadgets greifen ja damit kann
ich mit mama und papa wir nannten das
früher sprechen wenn ich vorher den
pin-code hier egal
ja nennt man telefon darüber hat mehr
angela merkel jahre lang meine texte
diktiert
badezeit ganz bittere woche natürlich
auch für den facebook-chef mark
zuckerberg
seine alte datenkrake konnte sechs
stunden gar keine daten sammeln und
weiter verticken als ihn allein
geschätzte 60 millionen an
werbeeinnahmen gekostet plus natürlich
die sache mit der whistleblower in
francis hogan hat vor dem us-kongress
mal ausführlich erzählt wie facebook die
gesellschaft mit hass spaltet und damit
weltweit demokratien schwächt also es
zugegeben keine ganz neue erkenntnis
aber dank dieser frau wissen wir dass
facebook sehr genau weiß was es an
richtet facebook fordert inhalte an den
sich mitglieder beteiligen die
hauseigene forschung zeigt das geht am
besten mit inhalt der voller hass ist
der polarisiert besser als mit anderen
inhalten
geschäftsmodell hast selbstverständlich
könnten wir ein algorithmus anders
gestalten zum beispiel mit sogenannten
riesch limit so dass sich bestimmte
inhalte dann weniger verbreiten würden
drückt auf den profit kann keiner wollen
permanente wut bringt nachweislich mehr
reichweite
sollte das zdf vielleicht auch mal
versuchen die piste ich die [ __ ]
oscarreif der facebook konzern erreicht
mit seinen plattformen fast die hälfte
der menschheit ja bei so viel marktmacht
bräuchte es natürlich mehr regulierung
des us kartell an will sogar die
zerschlagung vielleicht einmal zur
erinnerung der sturm aufs kapital im
januar der wäre ohne facebook gar nicht
denkbar gewesen
da könnte eine gewisse selbstkritik
schon angebracht sein sind einige leute
behaupten dass soziale netzwerke
polarisieren unseren forschungen zufolge
ich das alles andere als klar im sinne
von ganz schön klar dass der facebook
algorithmus hass fördert unverstärkt ist
sehr wohl durch studien belegt unter
anderem durch facebook studien er warum
hat denn ausgerechnet die afd die
meisten facebook follower aller
deutschen parteien
warum sprechen facebook mitarbeiter
intern von dem monster das sie
geschaffen haben als 1 ist die facebook
kampagne des militärs von myanmar gegen
die minderheit der rohingya hat zu
zehntausenden toten geführt facebooks
erklärung sie hätten halt kaum
mitarbeiter die burmesen sprechen tja
das internet ist vielleicht insgesamt
nicht so toll wie wir uns das noch in
den 90ern vorgestellt haben
[Musik]
schade
otto
wunderbar die junge dorothea und ihre
schwestern damals beim esc vorentscheid
96 6 stunden ohne facebook und instagram
davon werden wir nach unseren enkeln
erzählen wir hatten zwölf stunden es
wollte die firma junge und was da
passiert ist war übrigens regelrecht
gefährlich ja unverantwortlich geradezu
und nur minimal ein praktisches beispiel
zu geben schalten wir live ins
auswärtige amt zu ulrich von heesen
seines zeichens staatssekretär für
instagram und tik tok herr von heesen
wie haben sie diesen schwarzen montag
erlebt naja
katastrophe ohne den installer account
vom heiko hatte deutschland sechs
stunden lang keine außenpolitik also hat
jetzt vielleicht keiner gemerkt aber das
war dramatisch ich muss jetzt ein
bisschen leiser sprechen wir haben hier
gerade in shooting du machst das
großartig heiko und jetzt das face geil
geil im moment der install count von
mars ist die deutsche außenpolitik da
was ist sonst das machen wir ja nix also
außer uns moralisch überlegen fühlen und
anderen ratschläge geben klar das
aktuelle foto muss natürlich immer zur
jeweiligen krise passen hier denkt er
zum beispiel über die ukraine nach hier
über syrien und hier hat er gerade von
chinesischen kampfjets im taiwanesischen
luftraum erfahren das stimmt
außenpolitisch finden wir gar nicht mehr
statt am mittwoch hat frau kramp
karrenbauer zu einer konferenz
eingeladen zum thema unsere fehler in
afghanistan kurzfristig abgesagt hat
heiko maas
wir reden hier nicht über afghanistan da
ist er super empfindlich
nicht zusätzlich gucken sonst beschlägt
die linse
afghanistan ist sein waterloo weil er da
halt vorher ja leicht daneben getippt
hat ich würde mal sagen all diese
fragen haben wir die grundlage dass in
wenigen wochen die taliban in
afghanistan
das zepter in der hand haben das ist
nicht die grundlage meiner annahme
nicht gut gealtert
mein gott deutschland will doch gar
keine echte außenpolitik dafür bräuchte
man keine ahnung funktionierende armee
und diese ganzen erwachsenen sachen da
hat der deutsche aber keinen bock drauf
wir wollen autos verkaufen und gut ist
und deswegen haben wir mit maß auch den
perfekten außenminister gucken sie mal
keine versteckte lego
können nämlich sehen super versteckt
immer eine zugegeben im moment
beschäftigt sich deutschland nur mit
sich selbst aber eher von lesen wir
müssen doch irgendwann mal wieder mehr
verantwortung übernehmen in der welt
absolut ja
das hat der welt auch immer total gut
getan wenn die deutschen sich mit ihr
beschäftigt haben
jetzt lasst den heiko mal alle in ruhe
der reißt ihr jetzt noch die paar wochen
runter und dann kommt außenminister cem
özdemir ich freue mich tierisch auf
seinen antrittsbesuch bei erdogan in
ankara
nein schon wieder chinesen jets über
taiwan kacke was machen jetzt ich habe
noch keine fotos von heiko lustig aus
ich hole aus bärenfell
so fröhlich von hessen
[Musik]
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
mime hersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen
scheiß und sie töten - wollt dann
abonniert jetzt den kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal hersteller
[Musik]